beamen oder hummer bikes und und solche
geräte aus science fiction büchern
das sind super inspirationsquellen für
forschungsteams weltweit doch inwieweit
halten filme wie star wars dem
realitätscheck stand ein britischer
physikstudent hat sich jetzt mit dem
klassiker aus dem science fiction genre
beschäftigt mit den star wars filmen wie
viel energie ein lichtschwert unter
realen physikalischen bedingungen
benötigen würde und wie viel energie für
die zerstörung eines planeten mit einem
todesstern nötig ist jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
konkret geht es um eine szene aus einem
der ersten star wars filme also episode
1 die dunkle bedrohung der jedi meister
qigong benutzt ein grünes licht schwert
um ein loch in eine tür aus metall zu
schneiden exakt elf sekunden dauert das
ganze
der britische student lockt willcox der
university of leicester hat sich jetzt
die frage gestellt wie realistisch diese
szene tatsächlich ist die konkrete frage
wie viel energie wäre dafür nötig sein
ergebnis 7 megawatt das ist vergleichbar
mit der energieleistung von 70 autos die
vollgas fahren oder eines der größten
windräder der welt in etwa ob sie dazu
legt luke willcox diese hohe leistung
aus einer so kleinen quelle macht das
licht schrieb zu einem effizienten gerät
um durch dichte materialien zu schneiden
und druiden zu bekämpfen
tja und hier seine berechnung für euch
zum nachvollziehen
die länge des lichts schwertes schätzt
er auf 91 zentimeter dessen durchmesser
auf 4 cm die metalltür in der filmszene
mit seiner vermutung nach titan deswegen
verwendet der in seinen berechnungen
dessen spezifische dichte aber lob
willcox hat sich damit noch nicht
zufrieden gegeben
seine zweite frage galt den
unterschiedlichen farben der star wars
lichtschwert inwieweit unterscheiden
sich diese in ihrer leistung seiner
annahme die verschiedenen farben des
lichts also ihre verschiedenen
wellenlänge hängen mit einem unterschied
ihres energiehaushaltes zusammen sprich
mit der energie der lichtteilchen also
der photon die leistung des grünen
lichts schwertes hatte lok willcox ja
mit knapp 7 megawatt berechnet demnach
würde die leistung des roten licht
schwertes bei etwa fünfeinhalb megawatt
liegen eine violette waffe dagegen hätte
bereits 9,3 4 megawatt bei der annahme
dass ein lichtschwert ausschließlich
photonen erzeugt wäre die violette waffe
also die energiereichste doch wer von
euch die star wars filme verfolgt sieht
es eventuell sowie loboué cox demnach
scheinen die lichtschwerter in manchen
szenen eher plasma zu erzeugen ja google
cox ist übrigens nicht der einzige
physiker der sich mit science fiction
film beschäftigt und dazu durchaus
seriöse berechnung einstellt schon vor
einigen jahren gab es eine art
faktencheck eines forschungsteams um
david baltzer stone ebenfalls von der
universität leicester
sie hatten sich
gefragt ob es tatsächlich möglich sein
mehrere planeten gleichzeitig zu
zerstören ebenso wie in star wars das
erwachen der macht ihr ergebnis ein
todesstern mit einem mega leser wäre
dazu wohl tatsächlich in der lage
damals hatten sie ausgerechnet welche
energiemengen nötig wären um die
planeten zu pulverisieren für die app
erde beispielsweise hatten sie ein
ergebnis von 2 mal 10 hoch 32 joule
berechnet also eine zwei mit 32 0 das
sind doch glaube ich fantastilliarden ne
quatsch also wer weiß eine zahl mit so
viel nudeln also wie die genannt wird
schreibt es in die kommentare
und das ganz so vereinfacher hatten sie
bei ihren berechnungen übrigens
angenommen dass die dichte der erde im
inneren konstant sei das ist allerdings
nicht ganz der fall wenn ihr kein video
zum thema und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesse
nicht den auf die glocke nur dann werdet
ihr auch immer über neue videos
informiert ihr geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken star wars todesstern leser
gebaut ja ansonsten bis dann bleibt dann